nous on est au pays de l'amitié au pays
de oui oui presque dans le monde où tout
va bien voyez-vous grâce à à typhaine
qui régulièrement nous amène des livres
pour nos enfants et on va parler de
l'amitié quoi de plus fort que l'amitié
avec votre première sélection c'est
l'oiseau de colette
oui et vous allez voir c'est pas si
facile l'amitié et dans ce premier avec
ce premier livre on part à montréal
puisque l'amitié évidemment c'est
universel avec l'oise et de colette
d'isabelle arsenault publié aux éditions
la pastèque et colette elle vient
d'emménager dans un nouveau quartier
et puis elle part visiter son quartier
et les premiers enfants qu'elle
rencontre s'est pas trop comment les
aborder elle leur dit qu'elle cherche
son animal de compagnie alors ils se
mettent à l'aider sauf que le problème
et vous le voyez c'est qu'elle n'a pas
d'animal de compagnie et ce petit
mensonge va devenir de plus en plus gros
un fait
au fur et à mesure des enfants qu'elle
rencontre parce qu'il faut bien qu elle
brode qu'est ce que c'est ton animal de
compagnie va c'est une perruche il est
comment comment il s'appelle etc
ça devient un énorme mensonge mais ce
n'est pas grave parce qu'au fur et à
mesure de la journée et bien ne se fait
de plus en plus d'amis et voilà c'est un
très joli livre vous le voyez tout en
noir et jaune à mi chemin entre l'album
et la bande dessinée ça plaira aux
enfants à partir de 6 ans et on se rende
compte que finalement bas l'amitié c'est
assez facile il suffit de sortir de chez
soi
puis de ne pas avoir trop froid aux yeux
ah oui l'amitié un sentiment universel
sur la planète évidemment vient de
voyager là à montréal on continue le
voyage en bande dessinée cette fois
c'est oui et là on va partir avec bk et
grégoire malien en à la campagne avec
nina puisque nina c'est une fillette de
10 ans qui lance un blog parce que en
fait elle emménage à la campagne elle
quitte paris et là elle s'est dit mon
dieu où est ce que je suis tombé comment
je vais survivre dans un univers sans
amis loin de mes copains parisiens
donc elle ouvre un blog elle se dit je
vais raconter mes aventures à mes
copains qui sont restés loin est ce qui
est intéressant dans ses bandes
dessinées dans cette bande dessinée
c'est qu'on suit à la fois ce qui se
passe à la campagne donc la vie actuelle
de nina et ce qui se passe à paris
les commentaires de ses copains restés
là bas et donc vous voyez la forme et
traite
intéressante puisque aucune forme blog
voilà qui est cohabite avec la forme
bull traditionnels ça parle de l'amitié
de cette problématique
est-ce qu'on trahit ses anciens amis si
on s'en fait des nouveaux comment vivre
une amitié virtuelle et dans le deuxième
tome qui s'appelle le blog de charlotte
que je vous ai emmené et bien c'est une
des amies de nina qui décident elles
aussi de monter son blog
et comme elle elle adore la pâtisserie
et bien elle va livrer ses recettes et
elle va découvrir que les amitiés
virtuelles sont parfois et bien des
amitiés un peu vous compliqué à vivre
mais je ne vais pas tout vous raconter
ça plaît beaucoup aux enfants de 10 ans
j'ai testé vraiment c'est très très
intéressant pour les prêter à votre
voisine parce que mais avait dit deux
mots qui lui ont fait plaisir à la
diététicienne pâtisserie et puis le
deuxième c'est blog parce que on le
retrouve aussi un petit peu sur le net
aurélia jour martiale dans une petite
parenthèse edouard dumas l'entreprise
dumas se retrouve aussi sur internet on
peut aller voilà faire un petit tour sur
del 3i c'est à fait dans tous les
moteurs de recherche et on découvre
pendant les coulisses de cette
entreprise vous lisez tout à l'heure
quarante cinq salariés enfin c'est
costaud quand même oui oui tout à fait
c'est une entreprise ont fait 2 millions
d'oreilles et par an donc on fabrique un
une grande quantité de produits et ils
vous retrouvez tous les toutes les
astuces
si bien sûr sur des sites entrée de
gamme que sur le site de luxe ou là vous
avez tous les tous les savoir-faire qui
sont révélés ouais ouais pour parler
clair en va de la deux chevaux jusqu'à
la ferrari 1 vient enfin c'est en parle
à roye somme et logiciels et trois
marques comme ça y'a pas de soucis mais
vraiment il y en a pour tous les prix
ça c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment bien
on revient à la lecture pour nos enfants
avec une trilogie
oui alors ça s'appelle les mystères de
la respecte et je voulais vous en parler
parce que l'hôtel qui s'appelle lucic
hier à pajot et nivernaise et donc c'est
publié chez gallimard jeunesse parce que
son premier tome
figurez vous avez obtenu le prix du
premier roman jeunesse et donc depuis
et bien elle a continué c'est désormais
une trilogie
l'histoire est assez
exceptionnel en fait elle vous emmène
dans le pari imaginaire en 1899 est là
complètement réinventé paris c'est
devenue une cité état ou en fait la
science est une valeur suprême et ce
sont des bouchers qui un peu au main
mise sur paris alors pourquoi ça
s'appelle la respecte je veux dire
justement elle utilise largo débouché de
la villette l'ancien argot et la
respecte ça veut dire paris figurez vous
alors pourquoi je vous en parle dans le
cadre de cette chronique sur l'amitié
c'est parce que ça suit les aventures de
trois héros qui sont amis donc une jeune
bouchehr carmine liberté une
technicienne qui nous emmène à la
découverte de toutes les inventions de
l'époque
et puis un jeune orphelin nathanaël et
puis vous verrez il ya du du on va dire
du fantastique avec une mystérieuse
maladie qui se répand fin c'est un roman
vraiment idéal pour les jeunes de 13 ans
je le conseille c'est à offrir à tout le
monde il ya trois tomes le dernier vient
de sortir voilà j'ai dévoré je vous le
conseille
nous on aime trois belles découvertes
allez un petit bonus peut-être avec le
tfc luiz sami de masse potier et magali
dulin c'est publié dans une toute petite
maison d'édition qui s'appelle l'étagère
du bas et ça parle du fait que parfois
on a des coups de foudre amicaux et
c'est une petite louise qui rencontre
une autre petite louise et ça devient
des amis pour la vie
voilà parce que parfois mais on se sent
seul mais quand on rencontre sa
meilleure amie
l'univers est chamboulée et ça ça plaît
aux enfants à partir de 6 ans parce que
beaucoup se reconnaissent dans cette
histoire alors enfoncé une porte ouverte
par d'enchaîner mal articuler ce matin
on choisit pas sa famille on choisit ses
amis les amis c'est pour la vie puis je
suis sûr que vous aussi vous avez un
même la reine mais évidemment on a tous
savaient en principe les amis ils se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main
voilà c'est ça on peut les appeler 24
heures sur 24
je vous rappellerai une prochaine fois
pour que vous reviendrez pour que vous
reveniez gvt ce matin c'est compliqué
cela tu avoir un cerveau ça se bouscule
un petit peu avec d'autres d'autres
livres d'accord plaisir et j'espère bien